[Music]
i heard about you
didn't think you were real your guilts
have become your reason hate is useless
i will come for my great prize if you
want
the batman here is something that can
help you i have a stake in this world
and it's time i started fighting for it
you've fulfilled your promise
i spent a lot of time trying to divide
us
i need to bring us together
and make this right
[Music]
the bell's been robbed
up in the dark among the stars
the god is dead
[Music]
i had a dream
almost like a premonition
i think there's an attack coming my lord
this world will fall
i need warriors i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong
enough if you can't bring down the
charging bull
then don't wave the red cape at it
you're sitting here for a reason
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life
find out what that reason is
[Music]
they said the age of heroes would never
come again
it will it has to
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
[Music]
batman
[Music]
you